acredita nos jovens como
na criação de soluções sustentáveis
mas para problemas sociais entre essas
por empreendedorismo social e por criar
soluções simples para problemas
complexos
o menino e ar gostaria de ver o
conformismo ou aceitar as coisas como
são
1 a 1
obrigado pelo ex pelo convite é um
prazer estar aqui
obrigado a todos vocês
afinal são vocês que dão sentido este
evento
eu quando tinha 18 anos fiz o inter é
réu e conheci um casal belga e numa das
viagens do casal belga e entra eu ia
dormir e não sei se vocês já pararam mas
existe um tipo de pessoa quando viaja
com bola e outro carro
o avião partilha a comida que tem com as
pessoas que estão lá dependentemente
desconhecer ou não eu sou desse tipo de
estrutura mais uma vez fiquei na minha
caixa de chocolate com o casal desde que
tudo tem uma vantagem que é o facto de
percebermos a pessoa quer comunicar o
que é ter um carro e vá dormir nesta
viagem eu só queriam falar e então
falaram falaram muito explicaram que
estavam a dar a volta ao mundo que
tinham formado é que falaram dos filhos
dos trabalhos estavam cheios de energia
e só iremos tomar conta da viagem eu
lembro que meu primeiro comentário foi
fantástico estar em avisar os dois e
levou a solução é contar essa história e
um deus fez um compasso de espera como
se quisesse que eu percebesse melhor
aquela mensagem do que todas as outras
edições
estamos a compensar o facto de termos
trabalhado em trabalhos que havíamos há
coisas que não precisávamos e para
impressionar pessoas que não gostavam e
esta mensagem
talvez a partir de domingo tenha ficado
mais sensibilizado mas a verdade é que
houve esta esta frase há coisas muito
parecidas à lom
o da vida até hoje e vi pessoas muito
muito parecidas com vivências muito
parecidas ascendi parecidas
eu acho que há tanta mas tanta outra
coisa para fazer no mundo tem também uma
boa capacidade também de valorizar em
público vocês estão vendo é eu faço
voluntariado desde 15 a visita em um
estado em alguns projectos de
intervenção social e não percebo porque
é que nós temos tanto potencial de
antenas de tanta capacidade
não usamos um criminais do nosso tempo
pra ajudar para inspirar para resolver
problemas sociais
isso preocupa é eu não sou contra fazer
dinheiro rosa empresas gerarem um trem
por tantas empresas gerarem lucro é
importante nós ganharmos dinheiro o que
nós que fazemos a vida focados nisto nos
últimos nos últimos 12 anos fiz
voluntariado é e desenvolvido em
projetos sociais que faz parte uma cisão
que a seleção fazer avançar que deixou
aqui em leiria e uma cisão que acredita
nos jovens para fazer a diferença
acredita que eles podem ser
desempenhadas mudança e agente de
transformação social de micro chama eles
o que quiserem e na seção fazer avançar
nós fazemos formação para desenvolver as
competências está nos preparativos
resolver problemas
identificamos problemas sociais à nossa
volta para ficarmos mais sensibilizados
com outras realidades conhecer outros
mundos e tentamos criar soluções e esta
tentativa ou não criar a solução que
cristian ambos como agente de
transformação social
nesta experiência tive a sorte de
conhecer muitas pessoas que fazem a
diferença de formas distintas eo eu acho
que essas formas distintas cada em duas
dimensões principais e estas duas
dimensões principais ajudam nos a
perceber como é que nós podemos usar o
que tem mais de tempo para fazer a
diferença ea primeira dimensão é o
empreendedorismo social e
empreendedorismo social é um processo é
o processo de identificar um problema
ler sobre o problema conhecer esse
problema e tentar criar uma função criar
a função uma solução sustentável
escalável e que seja eficiente que
resolva o problema
há outras dimensões pequenas ações
aquilo que chamam equipes pequenas ações
do dia-a-dia e estas duas dimensões acho
que o importante é nós percebemos que
temos algumas idéias em como podemos
fazer a diferença do empreendedorismo
social desse processo eu acho que nascem
22 tipos de resultados o primeiro é um
negócio social é uma iniciativa e brida
vendendo um produto ou um serviço paga
suas contas têm uma equipa profissional
dele e também do outro lado uma dimensão
social que é pra isso que o projeto
existe quer resolver o problema teria
impacto social é parte do negócio apenas
trechos tentando cuidar do projeto é que
iria temos um exemplo no seu caminho ele
o isp os picos novo problema da inclusão
sociocultural e tem uma dimensão social
que é o intercâmbio de línguas e
culturas onde pessoas de diferentes
culturas e e país aprendem e ensinam
línguas gratuitamente uns com os outros
depois desta experiência ainda tem ainda
tem eventos para além das aulas e tem um
programa de capacitação spix social como
um todo integra valorizar a diversidade
cultural naquela experiências que as
pessoas conhecem o outro quebra
preconceitos quebra nós tínhamos esse
ano resolvemos o problema social
do outro lado tem hospital próprio que é
o que parte do business ea uma escola de
línguas baixo custo que é paga e onde
alguns dos tutores dos picos social
àqueles que passam pelo programa de
capacitação estão mais preparados para
fazer podem dar as aulas serem
remunerados por isso
o outro resultado possível do
empreendedorismo social são os projetos
sociais e projetos sociais pela sua
natureza podem não precisar da venda do
serviço
tem obra tem custo ou porque os custos
que têm podem ser tratados vias
parcerias estratégicas e por exemplo
aqui em portugal também o programa eco
chego é reconhecida e premiada já a
nível internacional que envolve por
exemplo
o que resolve o problema da solidão dos
idosos
ian o alojamento jovens estudantes
tenham limitações financeiras e funciona
de forma simples o idoso cego jovem
gratuitamente e jovem faz companhia ao
idoso importantes por nova é promove o
diálogo intergeracional traz mais força
e da indústria mas consideravam o jovem
a segunda dimensão som as ações duas
pequenas ações do viável e é aí que
entra a todas aquelas coisas que não vê
todos os dias como fazer horas
voluntariado numa ipss como escrever uma
carta ao ganho enviar uma mensagem ou
jantar com alguém que tenha feito a
diferença na nossa vida e que nem sequer
saiba por que explicar porque ela fez o
que foi importante
ou então surgiram fazer sorrir todas
essas coisas e as pessoas duas duas
grandes dimensões
eu acho que nós quisermos fazer a
diferença no mundo outras duas
eu acho que é assim coisas que é
fundamental saber
a primeira é que é preciso acreditar que
isto não acredita sente eu não vou
gritar em que é preciso acreditar
consegue e é preciso definir se é que
nem créditos ea causa em que acreditam e
principalmente trabalhar numa equipa
como a equipe trabalha em conjunto eo
que faz
mas por aquilo que acredita por exemplo
eu acredito que os jovens podem fazer
diferença e assim vão fazer avançar
acredita que os jovens podem fazer a
diferença eu estou na seção fazer
avançar porque acreditamos na mesma
coisa é que o caso se são fazer avançar
faz é muito importante mas o que cria
lealdade confiança e inspiração entre
todos os membros é o fato de
acreditarmos todos no mesmo
a segunda coisa é fundamental saber é
que falhar é uma escola que não se muda
o mundo a criticar é preciso hoje e
fazer ações ter ações e tem faz
eram muitas vezes e é preciso libertar
alguns de uma coisa chamada ego e
officer mundial erro aprendermos kuyt
capacidade de partilhar os nossos e tu é
também muito importante
nunca nos deixemos sentiram falhas
principalmente se trabalharmos também
uma equipa é igualmente importante
deixar a nossa equipa falhar mas nunca
nunca deixar que um membro da nossa
equipa se sinta o falhanço a terceira
que sustentabilidade não é wish hoje
para um projeto social negócio social
o problema da sustentabilidade não é só
desse projeto é do terceiro setor como
um todo e portanto já faz a diferença de
forma sustentável ou não faz
esquece financiamentos ou subsídios
quarta coisa que é fundamental saber é
que vem levantar sozinho normalmente
impera o próximo jogo
e é importante lembrar nos que é sempre
sempre alguém que nos ajuda o que faz a
diferença para uma vitória para
conseguirmos alcançar os nossos
objetivos é quinta é de que os heróis
não estão não estou na tv
eu acho que todos nós tivemos alguns
momentos da nossa vida em que fomos
heróis mas fizemos do heroísmo algo
muito maior do que nós é muito arrogante
deixarmos a sentir a deixar no sentir
que somos heróis mas eu acho que as
pequenas vitórias e esses grandes
vitórias devem ser curadas e devemos
comemorar também as vitórias dos outros
que estão ao nosso lado e ajudá los a
atingir suas vitórias e acho que todos
nós podemos ser heróis e diferentemente
da vida e uma última mensagem eu acho
que nós temos o poder de escolher seda
que queremos ser como queremos chegar e
quando creme certo é que agora basta um
de nós
usaram cada vez mais tempo nesta viva
pra ajudar para inspirar os temas
sociais e acho que o mundo vai ficar um
bocadinho melhor e eu acho que esta é
uma ideia qual apenas se portado
obrigado